it's the Blue Lake Kev show
we have a special guest his new album is
out it is a good album it is great album
fully produced by scram Jones absolutely
you've been talking about this album for
a while yeah it's about [__] time
grilling nemes is here ladies and
gentlemen [__] your life you [__]
dick faces I'm back for the 17th time
what's it like doing angel dust it's
[__] horrifying is it you don't know
what you're gonna do I remember punching
out call windows or I remember just not
being able to move I just I just
remember every time I smoked angel dust
I was just like
why the [__] did I do this would it be
like a like a cigarette like this oh if
I had two died two tests so when I said
this on my podcast outside with Gorilla
nems
the best part is amazing you're killing
with that number two after bootleg you
had Ghostface kill outside facts he was
freezing he didn't like and he's a
champion I was like bro you want me to
stop for a little bit like 10 minutes he
was like nah let's get this going it was
like this so
um yes I came home out of jail my man
gave me a [__] jar of dust I'm like
go get your money I put you on I have no
clientele I just came out of jail right
right right so I just wound up just
dipping every cigarette and just being
my best customer get this [__] fly
out of here bro this [__] fly bro
yeah
you can smoke
no we're doing a [__] podcast
smoke sir and then you get the dust the
the the the the the
tea leaves I guess right whatever they
do so you dip it no you put the flakes
from and into them in your weed yeah oh
wow what's the Highlight though
it's numbing like you just
I want to try ketamine I did that too
okay hoe you got a k-hole before yeah oh
check this I just remembered this story
so
I'm hanging out with this girl for the
first time
she's like yeah I know somebody got a
special kid that wasn't really my thing
but I'm like [__] it whatever
she goes let's let's go rob this this
kid
I was like all right yeah why not yeah
all right yeah so I put them in the
headlock put them to sleep she goes
through his pockets takes the [__]
this is July 2nd who knows the year
years ago
so we take it to her house I didn't know
how to do it but apparently you put it
in either the microwave or like the oven
because it comes in liquid but you yeah
turn it into a oh you put it on a baking
sheet the liquid heat it up and then you
scrape it off and it becomes
like a powder okay do you eat it or do
you sniff it sniff it okay you sniff it
shall we do that
July 2nd do it
I'm smashing we both butt naked
[__] on Academy
all I remember is waking up July 5th
she's still bent over and I'm over her
and I was like yo what the [__] just
happened I look at I don't even know if
we had phones when I was doing it was
today it was July 5th I was like yo we
missed the whole fourth of July we
missed like three days what the [__]
happened with both still butt naked like
what did we just both pass out and
[__] wake up three days later keho
holy [__] wow I'm mad I didn't tell this
on my podcast [__] that's pretty amazing
I'd like to point out that now I really
want to do it yeah yeah gotta make sure
you do it with a woman though you gotta
do it with my grandma I don't know if my
wife will do it yeah man being a married
man and doing drugs just don't mix it
doesn't I only smoke weed and I take LSD
spray apparently now [__] boring yeah
get a life hey you're sober bro I know
but which is enough which is beautiful
yeah what's the worst drug the worst
drug is [__] this is It's a mix-up
between
[__] I would say dust it's not even a
mix-up but me personally I know some
people that love smoking dust yeah I
just hated it I don't know why I ever
did it every time I was like literally
why the [__] did I do this do you think
if fentanyl was around back then you
would have tried it
nah well probably maybe on accident
right like you're almost like probably
couldn't avoid it the last time I got
locked up
I was I was already sober for over 10
years right
so two fiends came in it was like yo
Nims love your music yeah I knew they
was fiends so yo what's up man it was
like I was like what you got arrested
for they were like
fentanyl I was like fentanyl I thought
that kills you know I thought they nah
we smoke it we put it in uh in the um
tin foil foil yeah like I'm like damn I
thought that I thought like a little
dose would like kill your ass yeah yes I
guess now the fiends are like
desensitized to it bro if you go like to
[__] or most places in L.A if you
just see homeless people there's just
[__] foil everywhere they don't even
want Percocets anymore they just want
fentanyl they're like where's the fetty
you know what I'm saying it's like
this [__] was like this they always say
it's like this much will just kill you
and it's like these [__] are
smoking this much just smoking fetty
what the I think it's all from China too
shout out to China man they got that
fentanyl on lock bruh that's fairly from
Mexico but he don't want to say he lives
man close to Mexico well I think it
comes from China to Mexico and then it
comes over what the [__] is it I think I
mean I know that they they give you
fentanyl in the hospital what happened
to that crocodile [__]
what remember that [__] you've never
seen that [__] it's called crocodile
crocodile they were doing it in Russia
or some [__] it turns you to your skin
into like crocodile
hey there's some new [__] I heard out
here some like uh some sort of
tranquilizer people are doing this like
a horse tranquilizer that's what Special
K as well Special K is cat tranquilizer
cat tranquilizer wow oh it could be
whole strength of the [__] I did I had
to be a horse tranquilizer wow that's
just tranquilized the [__] up yeah put
you out facts for sure absolutely you
ever do DMT nah you no I'm ready I'm
really scared I really want to but I'm
scared nah do that [__] bro
if you're still doing drugs at this age
bro you might as well if you're taking
LSD spritzes they'll do the [__] DMT
bro what do you got to lose